- I think Super Bowl commercial
is the most underpriced
ad in the world.
If you said, you have
$25 million to sell something
I would buy Super Bowl first,
then I would look at Facebook.
Because I know I have
all America's attention.
The sport of watching
the commercial is real.
You're gonna either
watch it on YouTube
or you're going to
watch it during the game.
So, right now,
it's Facebook video.
I'm dying to see what Snapchat's
scaled API product is
which is videos
in-between stories but
how are we going to react?
Are we gonna be
sad that there's video?
Instagram Video has
gotten a lot better
literally in the last 60 days,
so I'm starting to get a little
bit more excited about that.
YouTube's new pre-roll
based on people's search,
that's really interesting.
So, it's one thing to run a
video in front
of a sports highlight,
it's another thing to run a
video in front of somebody
who last week searched
Knicks season tickets.
You have a totally
different lead there.
Whereas I used
to make fun of pre-roll,
and I even just did right now,
I didn't go further
down which is
but there's one product
Google just put out
that I'm very fascinated by
which is this search thing.
But keep going.
That's it?
Yeah, so that's
the state in here.
Facebook video is so underpriced
it would make your head spin.